hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
hanging with no clips so here's just
some general Insanity of the day
you're gonna have a tremendous platform
but where is that going to be on your
radar in terms of advocating for
um you know athletes all athletes
transgender have to be able to play oh I
mean that that ranks high on the on the
list of things that I'll be fighting for
and speaking up against you know
everyone has everyone deserves the right
to play
Brittany Greiner now adding her voice to
the debate over transgender athlete
she's a WNBA star slamming the push to
ban biological men from competing
against biological women Fox who has
contributed Douglas Murray is here on
this nice to see you sir good morning I
think the key line is everyone deserves
the right to play so she's now weighed
in on this she's got a big voice what do
you think
um I suppose it's sort of lucky that
Brittany grind is not just starting off
in her career because if these are the
rules when she was starting off then the
whole thing might be different the
problem we have in America on this is
that there's there's a very distinct
lack actually of women defending women
in the Public Square on issues like this
and that isn't the case in every other
country for instance in in my own
country of origin Britain
um they've been very very prominent
women not just in sports but across the
the political and social platforms who
who have objected to precisely this so
so when someone like Brittany Grinder
says actually I'm going to fight for men
to play in women's sports it's just
another blow against lots of young
female athletes she said she thinks it's
a crime I mean all I can think is that
she's just overstating it for some other
sort of purpose because I mean tread
back even a few years
wouldn't it be ridiculous if you said it
should be it's basically a crime for a
biological male with with huge shoulders
for instance to compete against women
and be allowed to beat them in the
swimming pool or in a boxing ring or
anything else it's absurd it's absurd
overstatement it's an overstatement it's
only coming about because there's been
so much push in recent years to push an
idea which is obviously nonsense which
is that biological men and biological
women are
interchangeable yeah